los países de la otan están en alerta
mientras las relaciones entre Moscú y
means dan un nuevo giro tras firmar el
jueves un acuerdo de cooperación militar
Rusia comenzó a almacenar armas
nucleares tácticas en territorio de su
Aliado hoy firmaremos los documentos que
definen el procedimiento para mantener
las armas nucleares no estratégicas
rusas en una instalación especial de
almacenamiento en el territorio de la
República de velarus en marzo el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin anunció
que iba a emplazar armas nucleares
tácticas o de corto alcance en belarus
lo que provocó la condena de occidente
Esta es la primera vez desde el final de
La Unión soviética en 1991 que Rusia
despliega armas nucleares fuera de sus
fronteras sin embargo el kremlin insiste
en que mantendrá el control del Arsenal
el presidente Alexander lukachenko
acogió con satisfacción el rápido
despliegue de cabezas nucleares
el presidente Putin me ha informado que
firmó un decreto para delegar armas
nucleares en bella Luz fue una decisión
sobre el papel tras un acuerdo verbal
entre nosotros tuvimos que prepararnos
planificar los lugares de almacenamiento
lo conseguimos Y ya comenzó el traslado
la firma del acuerdo se produce mientras
Rusia se prepara para una contraofensiva
de Ucrania esta decisión desató la
inquietud en los países vecinos de
lituania Polonia letonia y Estonia que
también Son miembros de la otan
Washington condenó el acuerdo y afirmó
que se mantendrá en alerta No hemos
visto ninguna razón para ajustar nuestra
propia postura nuclear en ningún indicio
de que Rusia se esté preparando para
utilizar armas nucleares desde velarus
sin embargo los soldados rusos atacaron
el país a través de belarus al comienzo
de la guerra del año pasado y efectiva
que 10.000 soldados rusos siguen
estacionados en ese país